[Music]  but without further ado this year's best  documentary feature nominees at the film  independence spirit awards  alexander nanao nicole newnam and jim  labret the one and only kirsten johnson  maite alberti garrett bradley to  moderate today's conversation  morgan neville my own role is to shoot  people that i want to share  them in life as really just me being a  facilitator  you know with a camera you've gotta find  your collaborators  and be curious and kind with them i live  in some ways in the  fantasy of the movies that i film the  camera  is for me a way to understand so much  more  about others and about my life so i mean  that's  self-discovery like on some level  what a year this has been for  documentary and we hear that a lot of  years but this year  it's it's really true